this video is sponsored by Squarespace
I'm proud to say that I'm a dude who has
a website I do a lot of things like
YouTube and acting and thanks to
Squarespace I'm able to have my online
resume if you will in a One-Stop shop
easy to share website of my own that
covers everything I'm into and their
service is especially nice if you're a
gaming Creator because you can do a lot
of things that help expand your
connection and interactions with your
community like using the member areas
feature to reward your most dedicated
fans with access to Unique gated content
or videos it's also super easy to make a
website that includes a whole bunch of
links to different pages because of
squarespace's Handy Dandy templates Each
of which can be selected and built off
of indefinitely and of course you can
remain on top of your click traffic with
the insightful analytics that will help
you improve everything from keywords and
SEO to tracking your most popular
content so if you have a community want
to build a community or are in need of a
website for any reason go to
squarespace.com and create your site
with a free trial and once it's all good
and finished head on over to
squarespace.com Bandit for 10 percent
send off your first purchase you won't
regret it and now on to the video at
this point I've repeated the name tears
of the Kingdom to myself so many times
that I no longer know what reality is
outside of the game what is outside what
are friends well who needs that stuff
anyway but before I pull a Zelda and
fall hopelessly into the abyss that is
my own Insanity here's the complete
breakdown of the events of the universe
of the Legend of Zelda from its
beginning all the way to tears of the
Kingdom so if it's been a while since
you've played Zelda or breath of the
wild you know having released six years
ago in all or if you've never played
breath of the wild but yet you want to
get tears of the Kingdom this video is
for you oh and spoiler alert obviously
in the beginning the goddesses created
the Heaven and the Earth amen these
three goddesses are collectively
referred to as the golden goddesses DIN
ferror and nehru after they created the
world they departed for the heavens and
at the point where they left the world
in omnipotent three-pieced triangular
Relic was left behind that embodied the
power of the Gods this Relic is known as
the Triforce and it's an limited power
would serve as the Catalyst for pretty
much every major conflict that was yet
to come to the world and trust me there
have been a lot because the power of the
Triforce could easily be misused by the
wrong person the golden goddesses
assigned the task of protecting the
Triforce and the world of Hyrule to the
fourth goddess named hylia now we've
never gotten confirmation on how hylia
relates to the other goddesses
specifically or if she's also a Golden
Goddess herself or if they created her
or something but for theories on that
subject check out some of my videos like
the twins secret or my collaboration
with Celtic on who this mysterious
figure is either way hylia was soon met
with a foe of her equal the original
King of the Demons named demise or more
specifically the bringer of demise
demise and his demonic armies created
the first war against hylia and her
armies of the light over the Triforce
which led hylia to send her people known
as the hylian's Skyward on chunks of
rocks later to be known as skyloft for
their own protection meanwhile hylia
created a weapon capable of harnessing
the power of the light in order to
strike down evil in any form and this
weapon was known as the goddess sword
which would later be forged into the
master sword and still retains its power
of harnessing beams of light energy to
this day hylia armed with her sword and
joined by the forces of hyruleans then
successfully sealed demise within an
imprisoned form underneath a part of her
Temple that she had sent Skyward
alongside the hylians eventually hylia
decided to become a member of her
beloved race of hylians herself and upon
sacrificing her goddess form
reincarnated as the girl known as Zelda
who lived in skyloft eventually demise's
right-hand demon known as girohim also
known as demise's own Master Sword
kicked off events that would lead to
demise's eventual breaking of his seal
starting with unleashing a tornado that
would knock Zelda down to the surface
far beneath skyloft however at some
point before her sacrifice the goddess
hylia had managed to place the goddess
sword inside her statue which had risen
alongside skyloft and because of this
Phi the spirit inside the goddess sword
and girohim's opposite was able to
contact a determined young man with the
potential to save the war world this
hero was known as link and was Zelda's
childhood friend together link and fee
were able to not only Forge the blade of
Evil's Bane but use it to ultimately
defeat demise and seal his Essence
within the blade saving Zelda and the
rest of the hylians above and hyruleans
below Well for now at least because
before demise had faded into the sword
he revealed that he had placed a curse
upon Zelda's bloodline and Link's Spirit
of the hero a curse which would bind the
fates of their descendants together for
all eternity a curse which permeates
still to this day now fast forward
centuries perhaps even Millennia later
the hylians led by the descendants of
the original Zelda who remained on the
surface following the defeat of demise
known as the royal family of Hyrule have
long since established the kingdom of
Hyrule and just like their ancestor the
goddess hylia are the Protectors of the
Triforce which rests within an alternate
realm called The Sacred realm the door
to which lies in the temple of time
within Hyrule Castle town over the years
conflicts have occurred time and time
again Over The Relic the most recent of
which was a civil war this war was
fierce and very bloody and even some
women and children fell victim to the
violence of battle one woman in
particular whose husband was likely a
soldier in the war became fearful for
her child's life and fled into a
Forbidden Forest in order to find a
place where her baby would be safe
unfortunately the woman died of her
wounds shortly after arriving in Kokiri
Forest but the heroic woman's actions
and saving her child and entrusting him
to the great Deku Tree for protection
would Echo throughout the rest of time
because her son would grow up to become
the legendary hero of time about 10
years later the boy known as link who
grew up alongside the childlike Forest
spirits of the Kokiri would find out
that the Deku Tree had been cursed by an
evil man link would attempt to enter and
save the life of the Guardian but it
would be too late before passing away
however the Deku Tree tasked to link
with leaving the forest for the first
time and seeking out the princess of
Hyrule a girl known as Zelda which link
does after sneaking into Zelda's
Courtyard within the castle the two
share a fateful meeting and Zelda
explains to link that she's been having
dreams of Darkness approaching the land
but that a boy clad in green would
appear to save them she also reveals
that at that very moment inside the
throne room the king of the neighboring
Gerudo tribe was swearing allegiance to
hyrule's King but that Zelda didn't
trust him because she saw evil in his
eyes and correctly believed that he was
actually after the Triforce this man was
called Ganondorf being a member of the
royal family Zelda knew of the legendary
relics kept within their care such as
the Triforce and the Ocarina of Time the
latter of which was necessary to open
the door to the sacred realm and
therefore the Triforce she then concocts
a plan to do just that in order to
obtain the Triforce before Ganondorf can
get his hands on it and tasks link with
aiding her in this Quest however
eventually Ganondorf learns of these
requirements and decides to storm the
castle in search of Zelda and the
Ocarina link arrives just in time to
witness Zelda and impa fleeing on
Horseback just as Zelda throws the
Ocarina to link in order to finish what
she started after a close brush with
Ganondorf himself link escapes and
obtains the Ocarina from the mode and
enters the Temple of Time he then opens
the door of time but one step Remains
the final key to the sacred realm was
none other than the legendary Master
Sword itself elf so naturally link draws
it from its pedestal but had no idea
that doing so would not only open the
way to the sacred realm but would also
render him unconscious for seven years
until he grew to an age worthy of
wielding the master sword this left the
sacred realm and therefore the Triforce
wide open for Ganondorf to approach
which he did laughing all the while
however hope still remained because the
Triforce sensed the unbalanced heart of
Ganondorf and upon his touch split into
its three separate pieces Each of which
rested within an individual who best
represented the essence of their
respective piece power went to Ganondorf
himself wisdom went to Zelda and courage
found its resting place in link and
while Ganondorf was empowered from the
Triforce of power resting within him he
didn't have the full Relic meaning his
ultimate goal of his unlimited wish was
yet to be granted because of this
Ganondorf spent those seven years
searching for the remaining pieces long
story short though eventually the hero
of time armed with the Triforce of
courage and highly his master sword
defeats Ganondorf atop his floating
Castle freeing Zelda from her
imprisonment however before Ganondorf
breeds his last he calls upon the
Triforce of power to transform into a
monstrous demon known as Gannon together
Link and Zelda alongside the new sages
are able to not only defeat Ganon but
also seal him away inside the evil realm
after which Zelda vows to give link back
his stolen childhood and uses the power
of the Ocarina of Time to send link back
in time another action which would Echo
throughout eternity because at this
point the timeline splits into adult
child and Fallen but that doesn't really
matter for tears of the Kingdom why you
ask well because breath of the wild
infamously has ties to all three of
these timelines that followed the split
at the end of Ocarina of Time and we're
not going to go into a timeline theory
in this video you'll have to check out
my several other timeline Theory videos
for that according to various sources of
in-game lore and lore found in the
literature creating a champion though
the two games that breath of the wild
definitively has ties to would be
Skyward Sword and Ocarina of Time which
is why I took the time to explain the
events of both of those games and only
those games here the important point to
remember is that Ganon was created when
Ganondorf a Reincarnation of demise's
hatred obtained the Triforce of power
and he has been sealed away and revived
and sealed again over and over again and
each time defeated by the princess of
Hyrule and the chosen hero as time has
marched on the last time this happened
was ten thousand years before the events
of breath of the Wild by this time the
hylians aided by the descendants of the
original impa the devoted shika Clan
were privy to the history of the royal
family and therefore ganon's eventual
return because of this the sheikah used
their highly Advanced Technologies to
create war machines that would Aid the
princess and her chosen hero in their
inevitable fight against Ganon which
they did however after Gannon was
successfully sealed away once more 10
000 years ago the king of Hyrule at the
time began to fear the sheikah's
powerful machines which led him to
actually Outlaw their technology and
command it all to be buried beneath the
ground this led to a split in the Chica
Clan between those that decided to
remain loyal to the royal family
following this betrayal of trust and
those that turned against them the
defectors called themselves the yiga
clan and are still active working to
bring about the resurrection of Ganon to
this day for 10 000 years Hyrule knew a
period of peace and even forgot about
the ancient chica machines and ganon's
eventual return until one day 100 years
ago when an unknown fortune teller
warned the king about the return of
Ganon now known as Calamity Ganon this
fortune teller also revealed that the
answer to defeating Calamity again and
lay deep beneath the surface of the
Earth following up on this advice the
king decided to begin Excavating large
areas of land in search of this answer
before too long the very same machines
that the king of ten thousand years ago
ordered to be buried were Unearthed the
current King also began studying the
legend of Calamity ganon's return and
discovered another missing piece the
power of hyrule's princess who in this
case was his daughter Zelda the current
incarnation of goddess hylia
unfortunately though Zelda's mother who
was also a descendant of hylia and
therefore had knowledge of how to unlock
the sealing powers of Zelda's bloodline
passed away when Zelda was only six
years old and one year later when Zelda
was still only seven her father
commanded her to begin attempting to
awaken her powers which nobody allowed
alive could assist her with meanwhile
the child of one of the Knights of
Hyrule a boy named link randomly enters
the korok forest formerly known as the
Kokiri Forest and extracts the master
sword from within proving his worthiness
even as a child and gaining him immense
amounts of respect and fame among all
the Knights of Hyrule reaching even to
the king himself however as Link's
combat prowess and ability to fulfill
his Destiny as the master sword's chosen
hero grew with each passing year Zelda's
story was quite the opposite no matter
what she did or where she prayed her
powers would not awaken several years
later in an attempt to still be useful
to her beloved land of Hyrule she
partnered with the royal advisor impa
and the sheikah researchers Pura and
Ravi in order to help head up the
ancient war machine effort leading to
this Princess Zelda becoming something
of a scientist herself together they
partially restore an ancient tool known
as The Chica slate and fully restore the
four giant war machines known as the
Divine beasts Zelda continues to Aid the
cause by taking over handling the Divine
beasts and sets out to appoint four
Champions to Pilot them she ends up
appointing one one member from each of
the four major races sharing the land of
Hyrule ravali champion of the Rito mifa
princess of the Zora daruok chief of the
gorons and erbosa queen of the Gerudo
and close friend to the late queen of
Hyrule the Garuda by the way have since
sworn off the admission of any men into
their Town including the rare Garuda men
due to the legend of King Ganondorf who
long ago became the embodiment of evil
and source of great shame for the Gerudo
who have been ruled by Queens ever since
eventually Zelda begins to research the
mysterious shrines located all over
Hyrule and how to enter them while link
has appointed her personal protector
Knight and head Champion much to her
annoyance at first although eventually
she grew to admire link and even develop
some feelings for him meanwhile monsters
had begun to appear in far greater and
more severe quantities all across the
land ominously signifying ganon's
building power and soon return because
of this her worried fathers persistence
on her learning how to harness the
sleeping power within her bloodline only
worsened leading to him straight up
forbidding her to continue her research
until she learned to master her powers
and on her 7 19th birthday exactly 100
years before the events of the game she
prayed one last time for her powers to
awaken at The Shrine of wisdom atop
Mount laneru but to no avail as she
descended from Atop The Mountain she met
with the other Champions who tried to
offer some consolation for her grief
their conversation was cut short though
because that was the very moment that
Calamity Ganon appeared and this is when
perhaps the darkest moment in all of
Zelda history took place because
Calamity Ganon had learned from its
previous defeat 10 000 years ago it knew
all about the powerful sheikah
automations that were awaiting its
return and therefore its first move was
to capture each and every one of them
including the four Divine beasts
slaughtering each champion and replacing
them with the blight ganons as pilots
and turning the automations against the
people of Hyrule Calamity Ganon and the
sheikah forces then swept over the land
killing everyone in their sight
including the king himself at this point
link who fought valiantly to defend his
princess was about to meet his end at
the hands of a guardian stalker just
before it happened though Zelda stepped
in between link and the Machine and
Unleashed a burst of power that
vanquished the power of Calamity Ganon
in her immediate vicinity she then wept
over Link's fatal state but just as her
hope faded a familiar voice inside the
master sword spoke to her telling her
that link can still be saved Zelda then
commanded a few of the remaining shika
soldiers to take link to the shrine of
Resurrection for his wounds to be healed
after which she placed the master sword
in the care of the great Deku Tree and
headed to the castle to battle Calamity
Ganon alone she was able to hold the
Beast Within the castle for 100 years
until link woke up in the present day
although his memories had unfortunately
disappeared aided by the ghost of
Zelda's father and the still living impa
Pura and Robbie link is able to slowly
but surely regain his power and his
memories and defeat each blight Ganon
and restore the Divine beasts to the
control of the Champions whose spirits
still remained within the machines he's
also able to enter the korok forest and
retrieve the blade of Evil's Bane once
again and together with the Champions
defeat Calamity Ganon and free Zelda
from within its Essence and finally the
princess is able to seal the Beast away
protecting the land of Hyrule from Evil
once again as the game ends the ghosts
of the king and four Champions are
finally able to move on and the princess
along with her Knight set off to restore
their Kingdom and that brings us up to
the current state of what we can see in
the tears of the Kingdom trailers which
we can still gather very little
information about I mean of course we
can tell some things such as we're going
to the sky Ganondorf is returning and is
where the mysterious malice substance
comes from Zelda's falling and the
master sword is breaking but that's
about it everything else is still very
mysterious but that just adds to the
impact that this game's story will no
doubt have on the franchise if you're
excited for tears of the Kingdom to come
out this may then hit that like button
knowing you're all prepped and ready to
experience the story of the newest Zelda
game and if you're planning on picking
it up subscribe if you haven't already
I'm going to be covering this game quite
a bit right here on the channel so I'd
love to see you stick around you can
always unsubscribe later if you change
your mind also before you go down in the
comments claiming there was a bunch I
missed in the Zelda timeline or that I
didn't cover the events of age of
calamities alternate timeline the reason
I admitted the vast majority 30 of the
Zelda games from this video is because
they're not expressly important to the
story of Tears of the kingdom and rather
just serve as references in the world of
breath of the wild I hope that clears up
any confusion huge thanks is always to
my Bandit crew who are the reason I keep
going with the channel and help so much
with the continuation of content that's
all I've got for this one so be sure to
follow me on my socials and I look
forward to seeing you next time this is
Bandit signing out
[Music]